the Joe Rogan experience DJ dad mouth is
my favorite character than everybody's
man with the McGee show that was the one
used to do that that was so loved that
you were doing that because I hated
those shows I was like why would he do
those shows what is the parable you do
morning TV dressed up like a fake rapper
she's it this day no segura created a
character called DJ dad mouth and he
would just show up places and the people
did not know what the [ __ ] to do with
him because the lowest rung in all of
show business is morning television
before next element I'm so sorry if you
listen to this and you're a local
morning television host look ice deliver
newspapers okay good morning host it's
it's one of the lowest rungs in all of
show bus it's a weird rung where you're
trapped it's like it's like you're
broadcasting out of like a Christian
convenience store or something it's very
strange
the worst part too is the four of us
plus like 90% of the acts working those
clubs do not have a fan base watching
that show you put it together you're
like this is definitely a waste of time
like we're wasting our time right yeah
and then if that's the only one that
morning yeah [ __ ] six to do this to
do good morning heartburn
and it only works when you when you get
in trouble yeah well you should get like
I remember one time I got shirtless and
went up it and the in the weather and
started saying there's thunderstorms Tom
did DJ have you ever seen mark Norman's
mark Norman's is great when he just goes
up and she goes how you doing he just
kind of gay let's get this started
hungover horny look at you I mean he
just like totally ruined it the
relationship for the club really didn't
know I went in there Tracy Morgan Tracy
Morgan's is my first one that's my
mating call
yeah there's Diane they are dying when
he does that big one in Shiki was in
Chicago for sure cuz I know you kept
hollering at bulls to give him like in
the middle of it and yes great his trash
I'm just crashed his two million dollar
Bugatti today
today yep a honda sideswiped him
hello in Hell's Kitchen arriving savage
ran into a two million dollar Italian
sports car Sam I saw I did a show with
him like a year and a half ago one of
the oddball shows and he came in a all
white Rolls Royce with a profession like
with a driver you know I got chauffeured
and he came in all white and had like a
[ __ ] enormous gold chain with a
medallion yeah
TM I was like that looks crazy he's like
like six hundred thousand so some crazy
[ __ ] this is today yeah this guy
sideswipe Tracy Morgan's convertible two
million dollar Bugatti what he's letting
people know well what's he Honda's
defense it's a very low car he is a high
car he probably looked over saw nothing
that [ __ ] you know is the car that was
like two feet off the ground yeah a
small car what these cars are so hard to
see if you're right next to him what
does that do his insurance say when he
calls you what yeah I don't know if we
can cover this I'm sure your [ __ ] they
probably that'll probably be like the
final straw
yeah probably kick him off the country
for sure with that Tracy Morgan
interview that was kind of but had to be
an inspiration during the DJ dad mouth
right to me that was the first one I
remember like wow I guess I mean someone
could [ __ ] what you can [ __ ] with them
in that way yeah I mean yeah I mean it
was funny because some people would be
really into having fun with you like the
Tracy Morgan people would they laugh and
have a good time and then some people
let me like I could see how a clone
relationship could because we left one
of the clubs when I told him I was
coming out as non-binary and the lady
was like what this is like on the air
was like different genders and she was
like all right and she's turning the TV
and she was like oh she's was and then
she called in that like we called the
the PR person that drove us to the club
or to the head didn't realize she's in
the car what the [ __ ] was that
she was like that was that guy is so
weird don't bring stuff like that in
here oh we don't want to come in here
babe they think that what they're doing
is serious we're providing a wonderful
morning show for downtown Pittsburgh
you're showing
to make [ __ ] I trust Rami saying
exactly so it's so dumb what what a
great sandwich hey thanks a lot we've
got the Christian he's gonna sing for us
next
I tried [ __ ] on the last time went
to Cleveland it was the normal that's
why the other relationship still fired
but I was like there was a doctor before
me I was like why is he worse [ __ ]
doctor Ralph had to do this on the way
out he put a sweater on and I don't know
it feels like you're stepping into like
Truman Show stuff so contrived there's
nothing real especially when there's
like a 22 year old PA or Associate
Producer one time I went in and I said
yet I'm already drunk from doing radio I
didn't just put the mic on my necklace
and she goes why go I'm gonna take my
shirt off she goes you will not be doing
that and I said you don't tell me what
to do she was excuse me I'll be right
back
and it came back and she goes what is in
your cup
and I said whiskey and she was like he's
drinking he's drinking she told on you
oh my god and I was just like I was like
we should I leave he just left his left
I was like I don't want to get anyone
fired she's telling you you can't take
your shirt off
so I had a drink yeah or have a drink I
love how it's like she's telling me like
she found something out you're like I
was poor you in front of everybody I
don't want to check out the bottle she's
at an insurance company yeah hilarious
and people don't know what job they're
in you gotta take it more seriously